[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to the MIT Center for
Art, Science, and Technology's
2021 Symposium, Unfolding
Intelligence, The Art
and Science of
Contemporary Computation.
CAST was established
in 2012 with the goal
of building and
building on connections
between the worlds of art,
science, and technology.
This is the third in
a series of symposia
that CAST has
convened since then.
And as with its predecessors,
we bring together
artists, scientists, engineers,
and humanists from within MIT
and from the world
at large to discuss
areas of rapidly
evolving research
and urgent social relevance
and to find in that dialogue
stimulation, confirmation,
provocation, intersection,
and, we hope, common purpose.
At MIT, CAST partners with
departments, labs, and centers
to integrate the arts
across the curriculum,
to enrich and encourage
artistic collaboration,
and to provide support
to faculty and members
at the MIT community
as they pursue
their own artistic
practice and/or research.
In addition to
symposia like this,
CAST facilitates the sharing
of this creative work
beyond the Institute
by producing concerts,
exhibitions, and
publications and making
them available to the public.
So thank you for
being with us today.
We hope you will join
us throughout the week
at virtual events addressing
the aesthetic, technical,
and critical issues pertaining
to artificial intelligence
and computational media.
We also look forward to
seeing you on Friday, April 9,
as the symposium culminates
with a live interactive event
to which all attendees are
invited in which you can join
presenters and artists
in breakout rooms
to explore hidden
threads between all that
has been discussed this week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to the Q&A panel for
Deep Time and Intelligence.
My name is Will, and I'll
be moderating the discussion
today.
We have with us four brilliant
speakers, who I hope all of you
have had the chance to
listen to over the weekend.
Their talks from Markus Buehler,
Holly Herndon, Gary Tomlinson,
and Antonio Torralba
were a true pleasure.
And before we get into
my opening remarks
synthesizing some of those
fabulous contributions
and taking us off on this
hour-long discussion,
I just have a few thank-yous.
Really bringing together
this kind of group
to create an encounter between
arts, sciences, and humanities
requires an enormous
amount of work.
So first, to my fellow
conveners, Caroline Jones,
Stefan Helmreich, and
Fox Harrell, thank you.
And I hope all of
you in the audience
have the opportunity to listen
in on their conversations
as well and join us in
discussions with all
the speakers that
they have brought
to bear on this discussion
of Unfolding Intelligence.
And also to the CAST
producers, to Danna and Heidi
and Katherine and Leah and
Lydia and Harry and all the work
they've done supporting us
in the background organizing
the communications and
logistics for today's events
and contributing to
the beautiful website
that they've created
that I hope you all
have time to dig
deeper on in engaging
with us in these discussions.
And also to Jen and Lucy for
providing ASL interpretation
today.
Very much appreciated.
So without further ado, I'll
move to my opening remarks,
and we can see the rest of the
panelists with us here today.
Deep time and intelligence.
If there were a single thread
that I felt knit together
these three fascinating
talks on sound, time,
and the formation
of intelligence
across scales and
modes of existence,
I would have to hone in
on the concept of variety.
The question of variation is
a fascinating one, clearly
central to Gary's attempt
to define radical niche
construction by sensitizing
us to the pervasive plasticity
of niche construction.
In that context
of inquiry, I was
able to sense the core of
the key semiotic information
concept when Gary
spoke of a bird
listening and singing as the
varied complexity of the world
proportionate to the
varied complexity
of the brain architectures,
thereby enlivened.
To react, to reach after
clarity with respects
to a genuinely
semiotic variety here
would have to enliven
a sense in us,
not only of the emergent
selection and optimization
of a function, say, for
addition or vocalization,
or for auditory
feature detection,
but a sense of the plasticity
of niche constructions
that take place
through a mind that can
relive the relation of interior
variety to exterior variety.
The sound of bird sing
in this light, sounds
by which a bird does
not merely fulfill
a reproductive function, but
rather relives a relation
to not only another bird, but
to the variety of song, senses
and throws a voice
from that vocal commons
in a new direction.
Recast the tone of
another, let's say,
play with, in, and through
the plasticity of the niche.
Learning to sense that
plasticity, to respect it,
a feat of reflection,
surely, and one
I believe the question
of AI training practices
can help us think about.
I would be curious to hear
Gary's thoughts and thoughts
on his talk that would help us
listen for the hints of when it
is that AI forces us
into thinking clearly
about the genuinely meaningful.
Does AI open up such a space
of reflection on variation?
Or does it lock us into a
thought of the functional?
Perhaps before we
ask, is AI as smart
as a bee, I want to hear
in Gary's final provocation
a questioning that enlists
us, asking, have we,
in entertaining Gary's
reanimation of the mental world
of birds and bees,
found our thoughts
wandering to a thought
or relation to AI that
sees the maintenance
of a differentiation
of the functional from
the meaningful at work?
Curious, then, to listen
to Holly and Markus.
Fascinating that both
of you also named
Bach when discussing this
concern over variation.
One of the central concerns
in training AI systems to sing
and play is that they not
reproduce in AI systems
aesthetic cul-de-sacs,
as Holly put it,
but how practically
to avoid that.
I know that Markus is
very interested in using
MIDI data to train his AI, and
that Holly and Markus both have
different approaches to
using either MIDI or audio
data in their training sets.
So I was also just wondering
simply if Antonio had thoughts
on generating and designing
audio training sets
and what stakes that
technical decision
has in preserving or shaping
data into something that
generates desirable results.
What is a desirable
result, then, a surprise?
An optimal performance?
A novel or meaningful variation?
Taking this thread of
data generation back
to radical plasticity with
Holly's differentiation
of sampling from spawning, I
heard an important distinction
being drawn, one
that would force
us to rethink the
plasticity of the niche
in the economic context of
the digital music marketplace.
I was inspired by Holly's
phrase when she pointed out
that we must remain
attuned to the entitlement
to a shared musical past
when building data sets.
Would it be generative to
invoke the concept of niche
and then infuse the
plasticity of same with stakes
cultural, political,
and ethico-aesthetic?
Does AI help us think about
the mutable plasticity
of the sonic commons,
in other words?
Scene ownership and
niche production
seem to complement and
trouble each other here.
And I would love to
hear further thoughts
in the vein of this role of
AI in shaping a reflection on
or even staging a variation
in scene construction
or constriction.
The idea of variation for Markus
seemed to hinge on the idea
that AI can add new information.
In his case, working with
molecular dynamics simulation,
that information
would be generated
by computers trained
on the archaic memory
of primordial forces at
work in protein folding.
Those forces adding
to and reconfiguring
data presented to our machines
from the musical archive.
Here, then, data
set creation comes
into dialogue with
data generation
and also points to the
mathematical and scientific
constraints placed on
information generation.
Professor Torralba,
too, in his comments
on the manual manipulation
of GAN-generated images
touches on the
concept of variation
when he suggests that neural
nets have imaginations.
In the history of
philosophy and poetry,
the variation of images
in the imagination
was famously called upon by
Locke and Hobbes and Hume,
Blake and Coleridge, and
made a point of contention.
Are those variations
always concatenations
of sensory impressions,
primary and secondary qualities
or properties of matter
reconfigured by the brain?
Or are their forms derived
from the mind or spirit
that intervene and shape that
raw material of variation?
With the manual addition
of grass neurons
to dome-drawing neurons,
those questions somehow
become more
concrete, less binary
in the hylomorphism
of mind and matter.
While we could localize
the function grass,
even in a single
artificial neuron,
those localized
manipulations produce
results that seem
to imply a network
of other related
functions, like on top,
yellowish, fuzzy, gleaming.
In seeing these
instances of localization
in neurons returning
weird results, condensing
so many categories into
a pixel distribution,
I was wondering if Markus or
Gary saw something to trouble
or confirm their thoughts on
properties versus processes,
patterns of energy
localization versus plasticity
set in motion.
Are neural nets unhinging
us from the object,
from stable
substrates configured
into materials with properties?
And certainly I can return
to some of those questions
and call on individuals.
But I will perhaps
leave the floor
open to see what reactions
this might have produced.
Holly, I see you smiling.
Would you care to interject?
Sure.
Thanks so much
for that overview.
And thanks to all the
panelists for your really
interesting and
inspiring presentations.
I really enjoyed getting to
learn about all of your work.
Maybe I could just touch
on some of the things
that you brought up.
I did kind of chuckle
to myself a little bit
when I was watching
Markus's presentation
and he brought up Bach.
Because in my
presentation, of course,
I'm using it as a
criticism, as you mentioned
this kind of aesthetic
cul-de-sac, this idea
that a lot of machine
learning research
is looking to kind of
recreate forms of the past.
But what I found interesting
about Markus's work
is that he's actually
bringing in other forms
through the protein
structures in order
to kind of open up and add
new information to the Bach
training set.
So I think he avoids
the aesthetic cul-de-sac
in a really interesting way.
Yeah.
Maybe I can add to
this a little bit.
I mean, Will, thanks for
the great introduction,
and I took some notes.
And there's a lot of really,
really cool intersections
that you identified.
But, yeah I wanted to say
that what we do in the work,
we're trying to put different
levels of information
from different species or
different scales on a platform
where they can communicate.
And we call it sometimes
interspecies communications
when we talk about
spiders speaking
with humans or, in
this case, for Bach,
looking at data that's been
generated hundreds of years
ago, speaking with data that's
been generated over billions
of years during evolution.
And we found that
that transition
into an abstraction,
whether be it
mathematically rigorous
like in category theory,
or using sound or coding into
these audible barcodes, the way
to do that.
And what's interesting
is that then you
have the ability to
use the AI or computers
as a way of creating this
communication in a way that
wouldn't be possible otherwise.
Because either the
actors are long dead,
or they cannot
talk to each other.
Like we cannot speak
to spiders immediately.
So I found sound to be
a very effective way
for this abstraction.
And adding new
information is something
I would say we have done for
many hundreds or thousands
of years, actually.
But computers allow us to
do this in a perhaps more
systematic way, or reaching
observational levels
that our brain isn't wired for.
So I found it really
interesting when
Antonio was talking
about finding
the neurons in particular layers
that [INAUDIBLE] in an image
or create dome structures.
And I think that's a really
interesting mechanistic insight
we can gain from
these neural nets
that it's really hard to
pinpoint in our own brain
why we can identify these kinds
of things in our own brain
very easily.
Yes.
I can comment a
little bit on that.
So I think that it's
very interesting
to see what these AI systems are
learning when you present them
with training data.
And it is true that
there is a piece of it
that is about recreating the
past, as Holly was mentioning.
But in this representation that
the systems are discovering,
which are not for humans.
Humans are only presenting
the data to the systems.
But the representation seems
to be somewhat meaningful.
And this is what
allows us, then,
to manipulate the representation
and to put grass in domes
and so on.
And one thing that we
discovered that it's not
just that there are
units that represent
particular concepts that
emerge just from the training
procedure itself, but
also these relationships.
As it was mentioned
in the introduction,
the fact that grass
only grows on top
of certain surfaces,
that was something
that at the beginning, it
just seemed to us as being
quite accidental.
But then we discovered
that actually the network
was learning all
those relationships.
For instance, there
are some units
that will learn to draw doors.
But now you can
manipulate them and say
where you want to have a door.
But you cannot put
a door anywhere.
Like if you have
an image and you
try to put a door on
the sky, the network
will just not do it.
Even though you are activating
the units that draw doors,
those activations
will not survive
the rest of the process, and
they will get canceled out.
And the network learns all
these kinds of relationships.
And one interesting
thing is that now you
can imagine a process
where you change
the way that the
network generates data
so that it violates some
of these principles,
and it starts generating data
that looks somewhat real,
but it is something that
does not necessarily exist.
You can start putting things
where it's not possible.
You can change the laws
of light transmission.
For instance, one
thing that we noticed
is that whenever
there is a window,
the system learns
that there should
be some reflections appearing
on top of shiny surfaces.
Well, you can change those rules
and start having reflections
where there are no windows.
Or reflections disappear
when there are windows.
And there are very simple
changes that you need to make.
So one could imagine
that eventually, you
could generate data that feels
plausible but is not real
and breaking that
cul-de-sac that Holly
was mentioning at some point.
May I leap in as well here?
The presentations
were all fascinating.
Will, thank you so much for
the wonderful introduction.
The question of grass
on the top of the church
is what I want to return to.
And Antonio, I
thought the machine
learning that was going on there
was absolutely fascinating.
I really wanted to press you
to understand exactly what it
means to think that there is
a single neuron, so to speak,
that is the grass
neuron, for example,
that has learned somehow.
Because, of course, attuned
neurons in biological systems
are absolutely fundamental.
The honeybee sucrose
neuron, for example,
that I mentioned
in my presentation
is an example of that.
And the sensitivity
of it is constantly
in plastic change in
relation to its environment.
But one of the things that is
striking about those images
that were generated by--
machine-generated images
after this learning
process came up
in the question of the
watermark that you mentioned.
It is to me exactly the
mark of the difference
between a machine algorithm
that has learned certain things
but doesn't know
how to contextualize
this learning in an environment
and a biological mind.
The difference is precisely in
the fact that no biological--
no human taking all
of those pictures
and instructed to
draw another picture
would include the watermarks.
And yet the machine cannot but
include the watermarks unless
instructed to do differently.
Where would you--
Yeah.
That's an interesting question.
The machine realizes--
well, realizes.
It tries to reproduce the same
data that you give it to read.
And watermarks are part of it.
Watermarks were not present
in all of the images,
but there is a percentage of
them that contain watermarks.
So what happened
is that the network
will produce, sometimes,
images with watermarks.
And in fact, we located where
those watermarks are generated.
And it's not just
one single unit.
Generally what you have is
a small population of units,
maybe 20 units out of 500, that
represent a particular object.
And in particular
watermarks, there
are some units that were
doing those watermarks.
So now you can,
for instance, say,
I want these units
to never be active.
And from that moment,
all of the images
that this process will generate
will not contain watermarks.
Or you could reverse it and
always have them active,
and then all of the images
will have a watermark.
So the system doesn't have the
knowledge of what this means.
So for a human, you could know
that the watermark is really
not important and then
decide not to put it ever.
But the machine, the
watermark or a door,
they are all equally important.
So--
I could actually
imagine-- sorry?
Please.
I was just thinking specifically
about the watermark.
It reminds me of kind of
[INAUDIBLE] expressions, where
artists began to
incorporate some
of these kind of aesthetics
into their own aesthetic.
So I could actually imagine
a kind of human creative mind
also integrating the watermark.
But then that
would, of course, be
through a kind of human
understanding of comedy,
or the context would
be entirely different.
Yeah.
And in a certain
sense, the context--
the word "imagination" came
up at the end in regard
to the grass on the
top of the church.
The human imagination--
talking about deep time
and intelligence, the
human imagination--
there's a wonderful phrase
that an archeologist introduced
30 years ago and
that has been tracked
in archeological proxies
across 500,000 years of hominin
evolution, long before
Homo sapiens came along.
And the phrase is the
release from proximity.
That is, what gradually unfolded
in hominin intelligence was
the capacity to imagine things
that weren't there, that
weren't in front of the senses,
in some cases imagined things
that were minimal
counterintuitions as opposed
to what was actually
seen in the environment.
In more dramatic cases, finally
to imagine things that never
have existed.
And of course, humans are
fantastically good at this.
This release from proximity is
a long-term evolutionary thing
that hominins have
come to be able to do.
Neanderthals were probably
pretty good at it too.
But certainly Homo sapiens, all
Homo sapiens, are great at it.
That seems to be different from
simply manifesting something
that never existed
through the machine
learning that you're
talking about.
And I think those
differences-- this is not
to underplay the
extraordinary achievement
of these neural nets
that you put together.
This is amazing, it seems to me.
It's amazing work.
And yet the gap
remains, somehow,
between what they're
up to and what
a human imagination, any human
imagination, can be up to.
Maybe I can share a
few thoughts on this.
[INAUDIBLE] This is a
brilliant, brilliant point.
Thank you, Gary, and also,
really, to the other ones.
What we've been
doing with using data
from original
compositions like Bach
was to actually seek
information that might
have been encoded in this data.
So we used MIDI data.
That's another discussion
on whether MIDI data
versus audio data or
fluctuations of that.
But let's say we take that data,
and we've been seeking patterns
within that data that
holds hidden messages
that the creator of this
data, Bach in this case,
or other people that might
have created music at the time,
have encoded things in that
data they weren't aware of.
So I'd like to hear, actually,
Gary's thoughts on this
on what the context might be
from your perspective on this.
So it's another level
of human imagination,
not just things
that aren't there,
but imagining things
unconsciously that were there
in the past but that
have been forgotten.
So these structures
of our protein folding
or internal structures
in the organs
weren't known at the time
when Bach created the music.
Yet we've shown that
there are structures
in the music he
created that resembled
biological systems that
have been evolving over
billions of years in the
evolution of proteins,
for instance.
I don't have-- of
course, Markus,
I don't have any
full answer to such
a broad and wonderful
question and the kinds
of questions that are raised
by what you've been working on.
And yet, what you are
demonstrating, it seems to me,
is the continuity across the
cross even cosmic dimensions
and at all scales, spatial
and temporal scales,
of vibrational essences.
Those vibrational
essences are in themselves
manifesting at least a
rudimentary structure.
The notion of vibration
is a structure,
it seems to me, a
process at the same time,
and a dynamic structure,
but a structure.
And so to begin to unfold
the continuity across all
those degrees of scale, the
continuity between that kind
of structure and the structures
that human minds come up with.
Will mentioned in his
introduction birdsong.
And of course I mentioned
in my talk about birdsong.
I am constantly wanting
to say that of course we
call it birdsong.
Of course we humans do all
kinds of things with this.
But to call it song at all
is probably a misnomer,
as long as we are imposing
some general sense
of the human value in song
onto those sonic structures.
But they are immensely
complex sonic structures,
immensely communicative
sonic structures
in complex social systems.
And all of it, then,
comes back to the sense--
well, the vibrational sense
that you are working with.
So my question for
you, Markus, would
be once you have
translated, for example,
the aria to the
Goldberg Variations,
once you've translated
it through the filter
of amino acid vibrational
dynamics, well, two things.
It doesn't come back as the
aria that Bach composed,
even though we could
hear traces of that aria.
We could hear echoes
here and there.
It comes back as something
very, very different.
But why doesn't it
come back as something
even further, even
more different, even
more radically different?
Haven't you converted some
of these amino acid dynamics
into a set of pictures that
is, after all, a very, very
small subset of all the
frequencies that we hear?
Right.
Yeah.
Correct.
I think maybe in
responding to that,
I'm curious to reconfigure
the question slightly,
to maybe bring us back to a
question that's coming through
in the backchannel
chats right now,
is that when we're having these
discussions about whether it is
merely a function or
some kind of meaning,
or whether it is a genuine
variation or something that
repeats a difference that's
already encoded in the data
set, I'm curious if, as
practicing scientists
and artists, if you
find yourself developing
an intuitive sense
of how to negotiate
those questions in the
choices that you're
making as practitioners.
So when you're searching
for a genuine variation,
what kinds of techniques
or choices are you making?
When are you confronted with
those almost ontological
conundrums through the work
that you're generating?
And I think that that has to
do with the aesthetic choices
that maybe Markus
would be confronted
with in seeing this new
variation of the aria
and having to decide whether
to perhaps change the force
equation that he's using
to model the protein fold.
Or for Holly, in building
these file systems
of all these
different variations
that you showed us
on these audio files,
negotiating somehow with
what the basic building
blocks of a composition
are as they're
derived from this engagement
with machine learning systems.
So yeah, I'm really curious.
And Gary's question,
too, but I think
that that dimension of
practice is something
that the audience is curious
in hearing more about.
That was directed,
I had understood,
particularly at Markus I don't
want to put him on the spot.
Or Holly.
[INAUDIBLE]
Or professor Torralba is
also engaged in the practice
of building data sets as well.
So I'm curious if that--
Well, maybe I can
briefly answer and then
everyone else also
say something.
But there are a lot of
choices, of course, we make.
And I would say a little
bit to the question
of Gary and the generalization
that Will talked about,
we choose, of course, the
universe or the platform we're
building.
Let's say the sounds
from-- and in this case,
we're working with
the amino acids.
And actually in the case of
the deep area we created,
we're actually working not in
the innate amino acid scale,
but in an equal
temperament scaling
to reflect back what Bach
actually originally intended
the music to sound like.
So we make a lot
of choices in this,
and it's a discussion
that's much longer in what
are the more abstract
ways to look at that.
And I think your
birdsong example actually
reminded me of that.
When we do listen to
proteins or structures
like this in the innate
vibrational spectrum,
we have a hard time
understanding them
and accessing them in our
brain because we're not
attuned to these ways of
thinking or listening.
So we are trying to make
choices that make it
accessible to certain regions.
I would say that we want
to make interpolations
similar to an expansion in the
series, a tailor expansion,
where we want to look
at a reference point,
in this case the aria, and
the original way it's played
in equal temperament and
then extrapolate from there
a little bit out, what would
this additional information
from protein folding
add to the structure?
So we can make those
choices, and we
can go either very far away, or
we can stay reasonably close.
In this piece that I
present in the presentation,
it was a compromise
between going too far,
but also being
able, like you say,
to recognize fragments of it.
And that's what I wanted to show
is there are these fragments.
You can recognize them.
But there are also
differences and distinctions,
which are very
clear, and they tell
the story of what this deep
time memory really brings to us.
So it's not the
computer alone doing it.
I think Will had that
point when we discussed,
and I also mentioned
this in my talk.
In the rendering of the
actual final product,
there are many choices
we make as humans.
And that's oftentimes
misunderstood.
You have these algorithms
that create songs.
And I think Holly mentioned
some of those things in her talk
as well.
There are a lot of choices, of
course, that we need to make.
And we're very far away from--
and maybe perhaps infinitely
far away from letting it
be completely automated
by an algorithm.
For me as a composer,
a practitioner,
I my ultimate goal is
I'm trying to create
meaning through the
artwork that I'm making.
So it's a kind of
meaning-making search.
And so, as Markus
mentioned, you can't really
outsource that to a machine.
Really, I see machine
learning techniques
as a way to augment my
process, particularly, ideally,
an embodied
performance practice.
That's where I really think
things will get interesting
and start to take off.
When we're able to,
as humans, music
with other humans and machines
in kind of concert together,
that's when I think new
aesthetic possibilities
and new ideas will emerge.
And so that's what I'm
primarily focusing on right now.
I haven't been focusing
so much on kind
of the statistical analysis
of certain existing forms
and trying to kind of
create new forms from that.
So that's another
reason why I really
tried to focus on using audio
material rather than MIDI data,
because as a sound
artist and composer,
I find so many kind of sensual
qualities in sound as material.
And for me, a kind of MIDI
representation of a piece
is missing out on so
many of the things
that I find sensual about music.
So trying to kind
of understand what
might be sensual
about one sound source
and then trying to
understand how I might then
augment my own performance
practice to be able to perform
through that sound.
That's been kind of my approach,
to remain in the driver's seat
of composer and meaning maker.
Yeah, I think there
is also something
interesting with respect to
the choices that we make.
There are choices at so
many levels, the data
that we use to train our system,
the representation that we use,
whether it's MIDI
or the real audio,
and also the architecture that
we use to process that data.
And the choices that we don't
make, we still make them.
We are just not aware of them.
So that's where all the
biases come in that creep
into our systems.
And we might not
be aware of them,
but the system is just trying
to reproduce what it sees.
And it's limited
by the architecture
and the representational
power that it has,
given the choices that you
made on how you implement
that particular approach.
So all of these
things have an impact
on the results that you have
and the behavior that you have
when you use a
particular system.
A phrase of yours,
Antonio, that came up
in your earlier comments,
"not all of the variations
survived the rest
of the process."
It was very fascinating to
me that you could manually
manipulate with
something in the system
that you're using to
generate a variation,
but that the system seems to
have implicit constraints built
into it.
That is something
that also reminded me
of Markus's approach
in the sense
that there are limitations
or constraints on the kinds
of data that he can
generate, and that
has an interesting creative
effect on the work,
that working within
limitations is one
of the interesting
aspects of the new kinds
of creative processes
that are at work here.
It's almost that we know about
rule-constrained art making
practices from conceptual
art, for example.
But we're operating with a
different set of limitations
here, ones that we may not even
be able to explicitly identify
if all of the rules
governing the net
are not completely
transparent to us.
So I'm curious if these
thoughts on the kinds
of limitation-setting
role of AI have been--
whether those have been of
interest to you as researchers
and whether you
wonder about what
constrains the
validity of results
in these sorts of
systems, whether it
be scientifically
or aesthetically.
Yeah, I think that the
way that I see current AI
systems, especially the
ones using neural networks,
I think it's been true
maybe for a long time,
but especially true
nowadays is that we
have these systems
that are composed
of very simple operations.
And they have to, through
these simple operations
and recombining them,
they have to produce
some complicated task.
They have to solve
And at each iteration
of the process,
I see it as a filter
in a stage, where
you remove undesired
sources of variation,
and a recombination
a stage, where
you try to find new
concepts from the data
or build a more
sophisticated representation.
But that recombination
process is very simple.
So the way that you build
a complex representation is
by removing undesired
sources of variation
and recombining the concepts a
little bit and then removing,
again, undesired sources of
variation in this new space
and recombining
again, and so on.
And that's how the
process evolves.
And this is why you need
a lot of different stages
of processing.
And in the case
of the brain, you
have all the different
layers of neurons
that process the
data just moving
one step towards
whatever task you
want to solve at the end,
whatever representation
you want to build.
And I think that we are
very interested in trying
to see how much of
that representation
and the way that that
representation will
get transformed is
understandable by us.
And I think that some part
of it will be understandable,
and there are some
other the pieces
that will not,
that maybe are not
because they are not really
based on rules, necessarily,
but are a little
bit more intuitive.
But I think that that
is a big piece of it
that will be understandable.
That's my personal belief.
And from the artistic
point of view,
I think that is
very interesting.
Then, once you have this
representation of something
and you understand some of the
rules, how do you break them?
And what are the things
that you get out?
And I think that things
like abstract art
and so on are maybe
representations that preserve
rules to some level
of that processing,
but they don't go any farther.
You don't try to recombine
those things together
at the end like real objects.
You are just stopping
very early on
and try to see, OK, how
does the representation
look like at this level?
I want to leap in here and
push a little bit further
on that word "representation."
It's a word that is used by
cognitivists all the time.
It's one of those
words that I have
trouble with because it's
rarely defined as clearly
as it might be.
A mental
representation-- this is
a phrase that recurs over
the last 40 years everywhere.
And we still have very little--
well, we have ideas about what a
mental representation might be.
And indeed, it comes down
to something that looks--
it seems to come
down to something
that looks, Antonio, a little
bit like what it is coming down
to precisely in the
algorithmic neural nets that
are learning in your work.
But, boy, here's where
my imagination fails me.
To get from there to what it is
that allows me to put together
a whole elaborate
context that tells me,
in trying to draw a picture
that answers to 50 pictures
that you've shown me, that
I don't need to include
the watermark, for example.
That, it seems to
me, is a huge leap
beyond what machine learning
is doing to this point.
And Will focused, in his
remarks on my presentation,
focused on the
question of plasticity
and the relationship between
organism and environment.
Genes are not what we
once thought them to be,
it turns out.
Genes are not blueprints.
They are, in fact,
interacting at all moments
with the environment
on all scales, down
to the momentary scale, in
fact, in terms of which genes
can be expressed at a
moment's notice in order
to direct behavior.
So they have a directive
executive function.
And yet that function is
nothing like a stable blueprint,
nothing like it at all.
So in that sense,
intelligence itself
can't be localized in either
a machine or in my brain.
Intelligence is localized
only in the process
that extends from my brain
out to the whole environment
or from the machine out
to the whole environment.
And so the gist
of my talk finally
was to ask whether machine
learning is coming anywhere
close to that kind of
hugely varied on all scales
interrelation and hugely
complex interrelation
between environment and machine.
Well, let me say one thing.
But I think that one missing
piece is the embodiment.
So current AI systems
are not embodied
or are poorly embodied.
And I think that is--
the case of the watermark.
Why are watermarks important?
It is really because
many other things that
are outside of the picture.
There are other
social implications
that go outside of what
the picture contains.
And AI systems,
generally they focus
on few sensory modalities.
Now that we've been
talking about audio.
You have images.
There is also the tactile world.
But it's when you put
all these things together
that you start grounding things.
And you still have
these limitations.
Even when you have multiple
sensory modalities,
you will still have some
other choices to make.
But I think that it provides
some additional grounding
that AI systems now
don't really have.
It's not that the research
community is not aware of that.
They are aware of it.
It's just that it takes
time to get there.
And I think many of the
advances that we are seeing now,
they have taken us by
surprise in the last decade.
And it takes a little
bit more time than that
to start building other things.
And there are still
many other breakthroughs
that are necessary.
Really all of this is
just now just learning
relationships between things.
And going through
a machine that is
able to have critical
thinking and things like that
is something much
more complicated.
Can I piggyback off of
that wonderful response
and ask Holly a question?
Holly, one of the last things
you left us with was the effort
to have spawn work in your
performances in real time,
in your live performances
in real time.
This seems to me somehow
related to the difficulties
and the challenges that
Antonio was just talking about.
But I wonder if you could
talk to us a little bit more
about how you begin
to close that gap.
Well, it became
really clear early on
that I wanted to remain in the
driver's seat as a composer,
so not to try to
outsource that job.
And I think that speaks
directly to some of your earlier
questions about
the kind of state
that AI finds itself
in at the moment.
I don't see it as
outperforming me
in that role of contextualizing
the world around me
and creating original works
that speak to my context
specifically.
So I did decide to kind of try
to focus on live performance.
But of course this
is a huge challenge
because with sound
and processing,
you have a kind of latency.
And so if you're trying to
perform, if you're singing--
right now, there's a latency
between my camera and speaking
to you, and it's already
slightly disorienting.
But if it was happening
in audio on a stage,
it would be almost kind of like
an insurmountable challenge.
So the real problem is basically
computation time and, yeah,
just the amount of
time before the signal
can be processed before it
comes out the other end.
So that's what we're basically
working on right now,
trying to pre-train models that
we can then perform through
that I find really interesting.
But another way that we tried to
incorporate some of these ideas
into our live performance before
we had the technology really
ready is we were
looking at basically how
as soon as anything
can become captured
in media, like an audio
file, video file, text
file, whatever, it can become
part of a training canon.
So almost as a kind of
public announcement,
we started incorporating
training ceremonies
into our live concerts.
So one of my vocalists
would sing a line,
and the audience
would sing back.
And we would record this.
And we have recordings
from concerts
all over the world with
different audiences.
And we can then
create audience models
that sound unique to each
room that was performing
because different
countries, different cities
have different vocal traditions,
different size crowds,
et cetera.
And so as a performer,
trying to find ways
to communicate some of
the more complicated ideas
to a wider public
through incorporating
the public into a
training ceremony,
but also trying to
asceticize the event
and show that it does actually
require a kind of human labor
and human expression in order
to create these training
sets themselves as a way to
try to communicate that what
comes out the other
end isn't just
some kind of random
alien-produced thing.
It's something that
comes from human culture
and human creation.
So, yeah, that's why
I've focused quite a bit
on where my training
sets have come from,
a lot about how we deal with
our shared human archive.
It's one of the things I really
enjoyed about Markus's talk is
that he's really thinking about
things on a really long time
horizon.
I've really been
thinking about it
on a kind of time horizon
of recorded media.
So we have this shared human
archive of video and film
and photograph, and we
can reanimate the dead
that we have an archive of
to kind of do whatever we
want them to do in the future.
And so I think it opens up all
kinds of interesting questions
about what we do with
that shared human archive.
So Holly, one question then.
When you use these recordings--
coming back to this
question of representations,
you want to be on the driver's
seat of the AI system.
So that means the AI
system is composing
the sound in some ways,
building some representation
that you can manipulate and
generate new sounds with.
And my question when I
was watching your talk
was, what type of
representations
or what type of
compositions are you looking
for so that you can actually
control them in the way
that you want?
So I have largely been focusing
on performance techniques.
So when I say I want to
remain in the driver's seat,
I'm largely writing the
phrases or the compositions,
and then I'm performing
them with my human voice,
but I'm able to
perform as a flute
or as whatever kind of
instrument that I've modeled.
So that's one way.
Or another way is sometimes I'll
write something and then create
variations on that motif
and then interject and pick
the parts that are useful and
interesting and kind of move
on from there.
I think a lot of people who
are coming to music and machine
learning that have maybe
less experience with it,
they imagine this kind of fully
automated black box, where
you just kind of type
in an idea and out comes
this fully fleshed
piece of music.
And maybe we will get
there, but two things.
One thing is the information
that went to training in order
to get the piece in
and of itself, that
came from somewhere.
That came from humans
musicing in space coming up
with aesthetic ideas together.
So that's one thing
that I don't think
should be forgotten or erased.
And the other thing is
that it's just simply not
that sophisticated,
or at least what
I've been working with is just
simply not that sophisticated
yet.
It has kind of equivalent of the
watermark all over the place.
And it takes my composer's
ear to go in and remove
the watermark or leave the
watermark, but with intention,
and to make whatever
I'm creating
have relevance to
the world around me.
Because music isn't
just a combination
of note relationships.
It's not like we can just do
statistical analysis on scores
and then fully understand the
human emotional aesthetic.
It's constantly shifting.
Whether or not an 808 drum
kit or a 707 drum kit,
that brings with it an entire
history of electronic dance
music to it that my
computer at this time
doesn't understand
at all, doesn't
understand that kind of
history or that kind of weight.
So, yeah, I think while it is
so interesting and so powerful
in so many ways, it is also so
limited and requires so much
of my own intervention in order
to make something interesting.
And that's why I think
it's exciting, actually.
Can I add another part in?
This is really great, Holly.
One other thing that we
have found if we are maybe
forgetting the AI component, but
just to look to natural systems
like a protein or
molecules or a spider web,
there are really interesting
musical structures in these.
And so some of the work we
have not with the use of AI,
but basically just
mirroring these structures
into audible sound or musical
space, with human choices,
of course.
They have to be made.
But there are a lot of
really interesting things
not using AI, but just
looking to nature.
And you can look at the
example of work on spider webs,
where you look at the
really intricate sounds you
can get as you wander around,
and the proteins, the folding,
creating quite complex
counterpoint structures
that are, however, not
necessarily the kinds of things
that we expect.
So it really comes
down to the frame.
As you were talking,
I kept thinking,
there is the moment of
expectation or the history.
You mentioned the great
examples of the choices
of the instrumentation.
And the same goes for the music
generated by natural systems.
And I think connects
also with what Gary was
talking about with birdsong.
These are not things
that we expect.
And I think one
future evolution,
I think as we become
part of the performance
and the observation,
as you are doing,
Holly, in your
performances, we actually
become part of the
experiment as listeners.
And I think the plasticity
that the species have,
I think we have to maybe
develop that as listeners
to music as well.
And that opens up a whole new
dimension in understanding.
And I think in the
world of people thinking
about composition and
how music is evolving,
that's more
prevalent, of course.
But if you look at a
broader public, an audience,
there's much room
to grow, I think.
And I think that's a great
opportunity for all of us
to work on and communicate.
And that's why I was talking
earlier about the reference
frame.
If we begin with this weird
reference frame that nobody
understands, we cannot bring
the audience to that point.
So I oftentimes like
to move the audience
from something they understand.
And so the aria was
an example for that
and moving away from that,
interpreting away from that,
and then showing this
other space that opens up.
But I feel also
as a teacher, you
have to bring the
audience from--
when I teach a
class at MIT, I have
to bring the students
from where they
are to where I want them to
be or what I want them to see.
And I think similarly
in music as well.
Antonio, I'm curious.
When you hear Holly speaking
about these ritualized
entrainments, this reminds me
of that ingenious and hilarious
passage from your presentation
with the greatest hits data
set, where there
was almost some kind
of theatrical presentation of
the process of producing data.
And this was another
theme that I also
hear Markus talking
about regularly,
about how much of the
creativity is going on in AI
and the arts has to do with
the generation of data sets.
So when you hear these
thoughts about the plasticity
of a public's perception
of a musical tradition
being the medium
that's being worked
upon through the practice
of training and AI,
does this incite
your imagination
as a practitioner within the
bowels of the Gary building
over at CSAIL?
So I think that the creation
of the training data
sometimes is a
little bit considered
like a secondary job.
That is, at least in
technical settings.
It's always a lot more
interesting to develop
the algorithms, and the
training sets themselves are not
so interesting.
I actually think that--
well, not just me.
Many people do-- but training
sets are actually just as
important as the algorithm.
They are the question
that you want to answer.
And the creativity that goes
into producing the data set
sometimes is just way more
important than the algorithm
itself.
For instance, what
Holly was mentioning
about recording different
audiences around the world,
that type of data is
really interesting.
And I'm sure it will create lots
of opportunities of producing
some pretty creative results.
The algorithm itself is
going to be secondary.
It certainly will
change the outcome,
but it's going to be
kind of secondary.
The main thing is the data
that was used to train.
And I think that thinking
about the training
sets, the questions
that you want to ask
and how that training
points towards an answer.
How do you avoid maybe putting
too much of your biases
towards what you think
the answers should be
into how you collect the data?
I think that those things
are really important.
And I think that, as
you were mentioning,
the training data
set is probably
one of the most important
parts of the creative process.
Can I add something
to that really quick?
So this is one of the reasons
why we like to use AI for data
from proteins or
DNA or maybe sounds
from spiders is because
if we filter them
through our own brain and then
extract information, let's
say for musical
inspiration, we're
biased by the kind of
history we have in our brain.
AI is kind of, for me--
and I think it was Holly.
You mentioned this in
your talk, that you
start from a blank
slate, essentially.
The AI has never heard anything.
It's never heard
any music at all.
So the first music
that, in my case,
I don't have a name for it.
You have a great name for it.
But our system,
our computer system
listens to these hundreds
and thousands of proteins
and has a very abstract
knowledge of these
but never heard any other music.
And so that sense,
it's a great way for us
to start from a
clean slate and then
incorporate the human
invention after that fact.
So we found them to be extremely
useful and important to avoid
the bias from the
human perception.
Gary, were you going
to jump in there?
I had a thought about your
work, actually, there.
And I think we might actually
be edging towards an answer
to your provocation.
Because if we were to
think of the AI system
itself as being
responsible for answering
the question of the
generation of meaning,
we might be missing out some
of these other observations
about how that algorithm
as an analog for the gene
is always within a context.
And that context
has to be something
that is transforming and
rendering plastic the movement
of the genetic code for time.
So you have to set in motion,
as you were saying, Gary.
You have to set the
algorithm in motion
through these acts
of contextualisation,
through these acts of
carefully managing the creation
and preservation of
an archive for the AI
to genuinely gain this
radical plasticity
of niche construction.
And this is something that I
find so fascinating hearing
about Markus and
Holly discussing
these various musical archives.
Because it does really
bring to the foreground
how this entitlement to
shared cultural history
is very much at stake
in these discussions.
And that creating some
kind of ground around which
to recognize the preservation
of these materials
and this data and
the organization
and structuring of
it is really what
will set the algorithm in
motion and transform it
into a process, to elevate
it above the emergence
of the function or
of optimization.
So these might still
be early beginnings,
but I think we're hearing
in this discussion
that the importance
of composition
and of contextualization
can never
be extricated from the design
of the algorithm, in that
the algorithm is nothing without
the data set that feeds it,
in other words.
In that sense, when I
think about an embodied AI,
I think these examples that
we've been hearing today
are all instances
of embodiment in AI.
It is not so much
about a body as it
is about a set of contexts
within which algorithms
are unfolding.
And the data sets
have everything
to do with those contexts.
They are crucial, as Antonio
was just making clear,
and as both Markus and Holly's
presentations made very, very
clear.
All of these are
reflecting human choices.
I'm not one to think that we
are anywhere close to a Kurzweil
singularity in terms of
AI taking over the world
and so on.
But what it brings home
to me again and again
is the miraculous nature
of even the simplest life
forms that we can think
of, the miraculous nature
of the complexity of their
moment-to-moment embodiment
and contextualization.
And this, it seems to me--
the challenge of AI for me as
an outsider to all of this,
fascinated by it but
very much an outsider,
the challenge is not to
create the machine that
thinks like a human mind.
The challenge is
to create systems
that are interacting with their
environments that approximates
some degree of complexity
for even the simplest life
forms interacting with
their environments.
Or so it seems to
me, but this is just
the question that occupies me,
I guess, when it comes to AI.
And I think it's a question
worth contemplating
for many years to
come, certainly.
And with that, we have reached
the end of our hour-long time
slot.
So I just wanted
to thank all of you
for these brilliant comments.
And I think we've made a
lot of connections here
that were nascent in your talks.
And I also want to
point out that we've
hit upon a number of topics that
will be coming up explicitly
as the focus of discussion
in the other panels.
The question of bias
in AI will be addressed
later on in the program,
as will genetic algorithms,
and data set creation,
and open systems,
and even later today,
unfolding models.
So I invite you all to
join me in the continuation
of these discussions
as we've reinforced
the connections to these
other important topics
in the discussion.
And with that, I suppose
we will sign off.
And I would like to thank
you all again so much
for your contributions today.
Thank you.